svgs are cool but even cooler when they  look like they're being drawn in real  time  step one create an svg path that is  styled with a stroke  and then export it to your html then add  an id to the path you want to animate  step two add a dash to the stroke using  the dash array property  but make the dash the same length as the  path itself you can get the exact length  of the path by opening up the svg in the  browser then grab the path with the id  and call get total length step 3 make  the dash invisible by moving it or  offsetting it by the same length step  four  create a keyframes animation that  animates the dash offset back to zero  assign it to the path and make sure the  fill mode is forwards so that it ends  with the fully drawn svg  and that is how a professional web  developer signs their name